hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to look at
creation and annihilation operators for
fermions in another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics
creation and annihilation operators are
central in second quantization
they essentially do what their name says
they do they create and annihilate
particles
and therefore they allow us to explore
the fog space we will also learn how to
use them to write stage of
multi-particle systems in a compact form
that will help us simplify the mass down
the line this video covers the fermionic
operators
and there is a companion video that
covers the bozonic case so you should
also check that out
let's go we start with the fox space f
for fermions
made by the direct sum over all n
particle totally anti-symmetric spaces
we consider a set of states u forming a
basis for a single particle state space
v
and we also write the fox state as u j
uk
and so on well remember that for
fermions we can write fox states
specifying single particle states u
rather than specifying the occupation
numbers because the occupation numbers
n for fermions can only be zero or one
due to the pauli exclusion principle
in this notation we know that the only
single particle states are occupied are
u j
uk and so on and that each of them has a
single particle
so the corresponding occupation numbers
nj and k and so on
are all equal to one while all other
occupation numbers are equal to zero
the creation operator associated with
single particle state ui
is c ui dagger and it is defined by its
action on a general focus state
giving this new fox state
what this means is that the creation
operator associated with single particle
state ui
acts on a fox state by adding a particle
to state ui so that the occupation of
that state goes from 0
to 1 and we add the state ui at the
beginning of the list
as we will see in a moment for fermionic
states the order in which the states
appear is critical
so you must remember that in this
definition we add the new state that is
occupied at the beginning of the list
another way to understand what the
creation operator is doing is that it
allows us to navigate the fox space
if we start with this fox state with n
particles it lives in
fn cui dagger adds a particle to the
system in state ui so that it allows us
to generate this new fox state with n
plus one particles
which lives in fn plus one imagine now
that we have a fermionic
fox state in which the state ui is
already occupied like this
if we then act with the creation
operator on this state we get this new
fox state
this cat has the single particle state
ui twice
and from the videos on the
symmetrization postulate and the
occupation number representation we know
that it vanishes
this is an example of the pauli
exclusion principle
what i want to discuss next is the
adjoint operator of the creation
operator
which is cui and we will see in a moment
that is the annihilation operator
let's write the matrix element of the
creation operator between these two fox
states
the bra has ui occupied and the cat has
it unoccupied
but all other single particle states
have the same occupancies in the two
states
the action of the creation operator on
the cat adds a particle to state ui
so we get the bra which stays the same
and then this new cat with the newly
occupied ui state at the beginning
the two states in the bracket are now
the same so the matrix element equals 1.
let's copy the original matrix element
again
using the conjugation property of the
scalar product we can rewrite it like
this
and in this last expression we can use
the fact that the adjoint of an adjoint
gives the original operator
to get cui here equating these two
expressions for the matrix element of
the creation operator implies that the
matrix element of the adjoint of the
creation operator
is equal to one star and of course we
can remove the complex conjugate because
one is a real number
this fox state has no particle in state
ui
whereas this fog state has one particle
in state ui fox stays from an
orthonormal basis
so the only way in which this matrix
element will not vanish is if c
ui acting on this state which has ui
occupied
gives a state that does not have ui
occupied this means that we can directly
write cui acting on this fox state with
ni equals 1
which then must be equal to this other
fox state in which the particle in state
ui has been removed
so what does cui do it removes the
particle that was occupying single
particle state ui
so it allows us to go from fn to fn
minus one
for this reason we call cui the
annihilation operator
we know from the video on the occupation
number representation that when we write
the u single particle terms the order is
important in fermionic fox states
in particular exchanging two fermions
introduces a minus sign in the fox state
this means that when we apply the
creation and the relation operators we
need to be careful
about the order we define the creation
operator as adding a particle in state
ui at the beginning
of the ordered list like this if we then
want to move this single particle state
to another position of the list
we need to make sure that we take into
account all the minus ones arising from
every particle exchange in a similar way
we define the annihilation operator as
removing a particle in the state ui
but only when it is at the beginning of
the ordered list
what this means is that if we use an
emulation operator for a state that is
not at the beginning of the list
we first need to move it there taking
into account all minus signs that arise
in the process
before we can actually annihilate it as
a simple example consider the fox state
u1 u2 if we then apply the annihilation
operator cu2 on this state
we see that u2 is not at the beginning
of the list so we first need to bring it
there
which requires exchanging u1 and u2 and
doing this we must introduce a minus
sign at the front
now that we have u2 at the beginning of
the list we can annihilate the particle
and we obtain a new state with a single
particle in state u1 taking proper
account of the order of the terms means
that we get a minus sign here
as a second example consider the fox
state u2 u1
you may initially think that this state
is the same state we had in the first
example
but it isn't because the order of the
terms is different let's again apply the
annihilation operator cu2 on this state
in this example the u2 state is already
the first in the list
so we can annihilate it straight away
and we get this
the second example still only has one
particle in single particle state u1
but it doesn't have a minus sign because
we didn't have to exchange any fermions
creation and annihilation operators for
fermions obey anti-commutation relations
and this is what i want to look at next
before doing that though i will simplify
notation to make the expressions more
manageable
and replace cui dagger by ci dagger and
cui by ci
where we implicitly understand that
we're working with the u basis all the
time
first consider two creation operators ci
dagger and cj dagger and assume i is
different from j
the action of the two creation operators
on a fox state will only give a nonzero
result if the initial cat
has the two associated states unoccupied
which means that
ni equals nj equals zero assuming that
this is the case then acting with ci
dagger and cj dagger on a fox state
first creates a particle in state uj
which remember we add at the beginning
of the list
and then a particle in the state ui
which again we add at the beginning of
the list
acting on the same state in reverse
order first creates a particle in the
state ui
and then one in state uj
we can bring this last term to the same
order as the original one by exchanging
the first two electrons which introduces
an overall minus sign
adding these two equations we obtain ci
dagger cj dagger plus cj dagger ci
dagger
acting on this state equals zero and
this in turn implies that this term
must vanish remember that for two
operators a and b
the combination a b plus b a is called
the anticommutator of a and b
and we write it as curly bracket a comma
b curly bracket using this definition we
have that the anticommutator of ci
dagger and cj dagger equals zero
although so far we have assumed that i
isn't equal to j if they were the same
then straight away ci dagger squared is
equal to zero because we cannot create
two fermions in the same single particle
state
which implies that this anticomutation
relation is also valid when i equals j
so what does all of this mean in the
companion video on creation and
annihilation operators for bosons
we find that rather than obeying
anti-communication relations like
fermions
bosons instead obey commutation
relations this difference between the
operator algebra of bosonic and feminine
creation and annihilation operators
reflect the respective symmetric and
anti-sematic nature of their states
specifically the reason why we have the
vanishing of the anti-commutatory
infermions is because of this step here
where we have to include an extra minus
sign when we exchange two fermions due
to anti-symmetry
in the case of bosons this step isn't
present because exchanging two bosons
doesn't change the state
so in that case we need to subtract
these two equations to get a vanishing
result
hence the reason why for bosons we have
a commutator rather than an
anti-commutator
before moving on we can very simply
consider case 2 for annihilation
operators
where you can repeat the exact same
exercise and we'll also find that two
annihilation operators anti-commute
again a consequence of the anti-symmetry
of fermionic states
so what about the anticommutator between
an annihilation and the creation
operator
again we first need to consider the case
for which i is different from j
this combination of operators leads to a
zero answer unless the state on which
they act
has one particle in the state i and no
particle in state j
so that n i equals one and n j equals 0.
acting with ci cj dagger on such a state
first creates a particle in state j
before we can act with ci we have to
exchange the first two particles to put
the particle in state i
as the first in the list and we get an
overall minus sign by doing this
we can now annelade the particle in
state i to get this final state
if we reverse the order then we first
annihilate the particle in state i
and then create a particle in state j
adding these two equations we obtain c i
c j dagger
plus c j dagger c i acting on this state
equals zero
and this means that the anticommutator
of c i and c j dagger is zero if i is
different from j
let's copy this final result up here for
convenience
what about the case when i equals j in
this case we have two possibilities
first if we have no particle in state i
so that ni equals zero in the initial
state and we consider ci
ci dagger acting on such a state
we first create a particle in state i
and then we annihilate it
acting in reverse order
we get zero straight away because we're
trying to emulate the particle that
isn't there
adding these two equations we find that
c i c i dagger
plus c i dagger c i acting on this
general fox state gives the same fox
state
this implies that the anticommutator is
equal to one
the second possibility is that the state
i is initially occupied so that ni
equals one
repeating the same procedure leads to
the same result the anticommutator of ci
and ci dagger equals 1.
combining these two results for the case
when i and j are equal
with the early result up here for i
different from j we obtained that the
anticommutator of ci with cj dagger
equals delta ij for fermions
combining all the results we just
derived we arrive at the following set
of anti-commutation relations for
fermionic creation and annihilation
operators
if should really familiarize yourself
with these because they're used all the
time when doing quantum mechanics in the
second quantization language
let's now look at the structure of fox
space and the role that the creation and
annihilation operators play navigating
it
let's work with a particular single
particle state ui and let's first write
the corresponding vacuum state that
contains no particles
acting with the creation operator on the
vacuum state allows us to go to this
state containing one particle in state
ui
acting again with the same creation
operator kills the state because we
cannot have two fermions in the same
state
mathematically we get this
we can also start from a state with one
particle and then apply the annihilation
operator to get it to the vacuum state
once we are at the vacuum state we can
no longer remove more particles because
there are none left
so acting with the inhalation operator
on the vacuum state kills the state
mathematically we get this
what it is telling us is that the
structure of the fermionic fog space is
quite different to that of the bosonic
fox space which i discussed in the
companion video linked in the
description
the bosonic space also terminates below
the vacuum state
but goes on indefinitely in the other
direction because we can add as many
bosons as we like to a given state
this discussion can be used to easily
construct all possible fermionic states
to do that consider the action of the
creation operator on the vacuum state
and we get a single particle in state ui
if we instead apply two creation
operators in sequence
we first get one particle and then we
kill the state because we cannot have
more than one particle in the same state
putting this together for an arbitrary
occupation number state what in this
case i use the notation with the
occupation numbers
n of all single particle states then we
can build it like this by acting with
the creation operators of all single
particle states on the vacuum state
for fermions we act exactly once with
the creation operator of occupied states
and exactly 0 times with all others
which means that the occupation numbers
n are either 0 or 1.
this expression also allows us to relate
occupation number states between first
and second quantization
remember that in first quantization we
can write the occupation number state
for a system of n particles
as equal to square root of n factorial
and then the anti-symmetrizer
acting on a tensor product state like
this
we can identify the right hand sides of
these two expressions and we get that
one
is equal to the other what we can do now
is to compare first and second
quantization
the first quantization expression on the
right ensures that we have a totally
anti-symmetric state
through the n factorial terms that arise
from the application of the
anti-symmetrizer s minus
by contrast the second quantization
expression on the left captures all the
subtleties associated with the
anti-symmetry of the state
through the creation operators which we
have seen obey a set of anti-commutation
relations
that are a direct consequence of the
anti-symmetry of the state
the final thing i want to discuss before
wrapping up is the occupation number
operator
and we write it as nui equal to cui
dagger
cui to see why this is called the
occupation number operator we have two
possibilities
the first is that ni equals zero in
which case we get
any ui acting on this state that has no
ui entry
we can explicitly write out the operator
in terms of creation and annihilation
operators
and then the inhalation operator kills
the state because it doesn't have a
particle in state ui
the second possibility is that ni equals
1 so there is a particle in state ui
acting with ni on this state we can
again write out
ni then annihilate the particle
and then create it again what these two
relations show is that the fox states
are the eigenstate of the occupation
number operator
and the eigenvalues simply tell us how
many particles are in that state
now for fermions we have been discussing
that we have to be careful with the
order of the u terms
so you may think that i tricked you here
by conveniently placing the state i'm
annihilating and creating in the first
entry already
it turns out that the result is actually
valid irrespective of the order
this is because if the ui state starts
somewhere in the list that is not the
first position like this
what we have to do then is to perform p
exchanges
and these p exchanges result in a factor
of minus one to the p
to get it to the first place then we can
apply the occupation number operator to
recover the same state
and then we perform another p exchanges
so another factor of -1 to the p
to take it back where it started this
means that we have two factors of -1 to
the p
so that the overall factor is minus 1 to
the 2p and this is always equal to 1.
this means that there is never an
overall minus sign and the occupation
number operator really does count the
number of occupied states
with this result we can now construct
the operator associated with the total
number of particles
like this or again explicitly in terms
of creation
and annihilation operators
to finish let's compare the fermionic
creation and annihilation operators
with the corresponding bosonic operators
and for the latter you can find a
detailed discussion in the companion
video linked in the description
what we have found in this video is that
the creation and annihilation operators
for fermions obey these anti-commutation
relations
which are a direct consequence of the
anti-symmetric nature of fermionic
states
by contrast in the video on bosonic
creation and annihilation operators
we find that they instead obey
commutation relations
and again these are a consequence of the
symmetric nature of bosonic states
the anti-commutation algebra of
fermionic creation annihilation
operators captures
all the subtleties associated with the
anti-symmetry of fermionic states
this forms the basis of describing
fermions in second quantization
don't forget to check the companion
video on bosons if you haven't yet
and if you liked the video please
subscribe